the CBS drama bluebloods is about to
celebrate a big milestone the series
will air its one hundred and fiftieth
episodes this Friday thank you very much
it calls the lives of four generations
of New York City police officers Blue
Bloods was recently renewed for an
eighth season TV legend you're a legend
Tom Selleck praise New York City Police
Commissioner Frank Reagan Bridget
Moynahan plays SELEX daughter Erin she's
an assistant district attorney in will
Estes is Jamie he's the youngest
remember the family who graduated from
Harvard Law School became a cop on
Friday night's episode the Reagan family
discusses life after retirement what are
you gonna do when you retire from 1pp
dead just retire huh fat chance you
wouldn't last a week
oh come on isn't there something you
always secretly wanted to do there is
what operative word secretly I love my
second career yeah what's your new
career being patriarch of this family
what exactly does that entail don't
encourage him these are my vast
experience and accrued wisdom to pull
out where you all are fallen short gosh
I love those dinner scenes we're pleased
to welcome Tom Selleck Bridget Moynahan
and we'll that's us to studio 57
congratulations guys you've been picked
up for at 8:00 season so I think there's
a cure King well let's start with you
because everybody always says it's a
chemistry we all get along so well and I
do think that's true but what do you
think the magic is in the past seven
seas for you um I think you know it
started with a great script I think it
always starts with a great story and
then you know it sort of clicked from
beginning one of the first scenes that
we shot was the family dinner scene it's
like you guys I look in the pilot you
guys have all been family your whole
lives and action and yeah something
about it work I guess that was a little
scary because we want no relationship we
just kind of said how do you do and down
to family and that's called acting it's
also called good scripts yeah as you
said well it's a writing but the family
dinners I'm always fascinated by that
because when I was a kid we ate dinner
as a family but people don't do that now
do you think people like it so much
because they do it and it resonates or
they don't do it and they want to I
think both I think some had it and don't
anymore some never had it
which they did and I I think mostly in
our culture doesn't happen anymore a
little Bridgette what we send it I I
heard from a few people who have started
having family dinner on Friday night so
they can roll right into Blue Bloods so
there's no make an event of their own
and then watch yeah I should point out
family dinners are not the Waltons our
best ones and oddly enough I think our
most emotional ones are when we fight
what do you do for the show there
they're not a recap of what the show has
has transpired in because it's usually
in the third act but but the audience it
provides the audience with a secret they
know what what wills done and Brigette's
done during the show or I've done and
what we've been going through so when a
subject comes up they're holding a
little bit of a private knowledge of
that's not going to go very well and I
really do think that's in Magnum it was
he had a narration he always shared with
the audience a private conversation I
think those things are very useful are
you what do you think is that the
challenge going into an eighth season me
how do you keep it new and relevant well
I think I have noticed that the writing
has gotten better year after year so
we're very thankful and feel blessed
about that because you know after seven
years it could get a little stale but
luckily we have a bunch of writers and
people who really care about the show
who keep coming up with really smart
ideas and storylines which is good
because we're about to go eat for eight
hours with the same food in front of us
Richard you told somebody you'd rather
be your age now than 26 yes because
speak what is your age now do you mind I
I thought I found out I'm 45 I was
surprised to hear that in the interview
but I'm 45 and I just think I'm calmer
and more confident feel more grounded
and a lot of the things that really got
me worked up or worried as a younger
person just kind of rolls right off so
I'd much rather be bridge is one of the
main motivators keeping the show
on those long days get it together
she also is emotional to get a little
goofy after about 6 or front of the same
food that's why you Russia's yeah do you
think when you think of Blue Bloods and
Tom Selleck and magnum p.i has blue
bloods been on longer than magnum p.i
and I can't remember know you mr. legend
but we're approaching we will have as of
this show we're doing right now that's
155 and next year nine shows in I feel
real funny about that
how so such an important natural such an
important thing and my wife I you know
and I consider this equally as much of a
gift so maybe we ought to tie I don't
know but I think we all might works yeah
it's high it's gone straight through it
you're still enjoying it aren't you will
eight seasons in yes after well normally
when you hit this point we were going
okay I don't want to be identified as
this character any longer it's time to
move on you're not thinking that no I
don't think so I think it's what Bridget
said and I I think Tom will concur the
writing the writing stays stays good and
I think you know we want to be here
until the story it the shows resonated
with people for you know some of the
reasons we've talked about and uh I
think I think there's more stories to be
told so I'm very happy if a shows at the
character-driven show yeah the
characters are they're allowed to grow
and change and the similar story for
wills character now would be so
different than the first year I didn't I
actor influenced that growth in terms of
happy I thank you so I mean you no
matter how much you're pretending or
someone else you're still using what we
call your own instrument and additions
your notes reflect the character often
and and your sensibilities the
commissioners a little flawed though Tom
yes he's got some issues he's shot he
takes out a lot of his problems the way
to 35,000 lives on his shoulder on his
people at work he has a pretty good
double standard with the family his sons
he absolutely is an absolute hard ask
you say that again about showing any
favoritism and he's always hitting his
daughter up for favours from the DA's
office that's good with your
commissioner barely business indeed
congratulations congratulations great to
see we like success on CBS the 150th
episode of Blue Bloods airs is Friday at
10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS
yeah